- It's great to see you all here.
My name is Sarthak Handa.
I'm a principal product manager
with Bedrock AgentCore team,
and I'm joined by Vivek Bhadauria,
who's my principal engineer counterpart.
And today we are going
to talk about something
that every team building AI
systems deeply care about,
how to keep your agents out of trouble.
We are an exciting point in the industry
where how software is
getting built and used
is rapidly evolving.
Startups and enterprise teams are building
completely new agent applications
that can understand users' goals
and then work across
tools to get the job done.
But the moment you start giving agents
the ability to take real-world actions,
like calling APIs, updating
records, or making transactions,
every misstep can have
real-world consequences.
So in today's session,
our goal is to explore how we can ensure
that the agents act safely
within their intended boundaries
so that we can deploy them in
our most valuable workflows
and give it increasing level of autonomy.
We'll first start with why this matters,
the promise of AI agents,
and what can go wrong
if the right control
mechanisms are not in place.
Then, we'll walk through different layers
of agent safety controls
that are needed to put
agents in production.
And finally, we'll go deeper
on how you can implement
these controls using AgentCore
and walk through a deep dive example.
So let's jump right in.
AI agents are a new
uniquely powerful class
of software system
that are able to understand
user's intent, plan actions,
and execute multi-step workflows
in order to achieve a goal.
It's a fundamental shift
in what software is capable of doing.
Unlike traditional programs
which follows a fixed set of rules,
agents figure out how to
achieve a goal dynamically,
which makes them a lot more adaptive,
context-aware, and flexible.
This adaptability is already transforming
how enterprises are using
software in their daily workflows.
We are seeing customers
across every single industry vertical
gaining immense value from agents
in automating complex workflows.
Think of automating IT ticketing process,
where you triage and
resolve certain tickets.
Agents are also being used to
generate structured content,
like knowledge artifacts, design assets,
or even software code,
in ways that were completely
unthinkable just a year back.
And finally, we are seeing
a lot of adoption of agents
for decision support,
where agents assist humans by
gathering the right context,
surfacing key insights, and
taking actions on their behalf.
But what makes agents powerful
also makes them high stakes.
AI agents can take unsafe actions
without the right boundaries and controls,
and this is a big
problem for organizations
who are trying to scale
their agentic workloads.
In the real world,
using AI agents can produce
several risks and challenges.
First, agents have
unpredictable runtime behavior.
Even when you design
your agents carefully,
the agent's decisions at runtime
often depends on the evolving
context of user's input
and tool responses,
all of which cannot be
predicted completely
during the design phase.
Second, agents may attend to take actions
that are outside their intended scope.
Think of agents' trying
to trigger workflows
that are only meant for admins,
or agents trying to kickstart
a high-value transaction
without the right authorization.
Agents may try to access
and modify sensitive data,
or they may completely
misinterpret business rules.
For example,
taking actions that are
aligned with users' intent
but not align with
company's internal policies.
So the real question is,
how do we give agents the freedom to act
while making sure that they do follow
the intended boundaries?
Let's try to understand
that with an example.
The right mental model to
think about agent safety
is to treat it as layers of protection.
You want to control how the agents run,
control what it's allowed to do,
and also verify what it actually did.
Agent safety starts at the runtime layer.
In this particular place,
the key goal is to ensure
that the agents execute in
a fully isolated environment
so that one user's workload
does not interfere with that of another.
This is your first line of defense,
where you establish a safe boundary
that contains what can actually
happen during execution.
Now, once your agent is safely executing,
the next step is to
give it access to tools
so that it can take
meaningful actions in runtime.
You wanna give your agents
access to tools, APIs,
and services via a gateway
that acts as a controlled boundary
through which every single
tool called must pass.
It is exactly at this boundary
that you want to implement policies
which allows you to define
and enforce fine-grained rules
on what your agent can do
and under what conditions.
So, for example, in this particular case,
you can define a policy which says,
"Don't approve a claim
above a certain threshold."
Now, let's say your agent has executed,
the next obvious step is to
know what it actually did
and how did it perform,
and that's precisely where
Observability and Evaluations
come into play.
In this particular layer,
the key goal is to be able to trace
every single agent decision
that was being made during execution
so that you can see which tools
did the agent try to invoke,
whether those tools were allowed
or denied based on policies,
and what was the final outcome.
Now this brings together
the entire safety framework
where different layers
help you contain, control,
and verify agent's behavior
so that you are sure that
they do actually follow
the intended boundaries that you plan for.
Now, to dive further
into how you can implement
some of these controls
with AgentCore, I would like
to welcome Vivek on stage.
- Thanks, Sarthak.
I'm going to dive deeper
into how specifically
AgentCore helps here.
And I'm going to start with
maybe a quick raise of hands.
How many of you have built an AI agent?
Cool.
Quite a few.
How many of you have
actually put into production?
Okay, one.
How many of you who
have put into production
actually feel safe about the
security controls that you have
in production for AI agents?
Yeah, and that's expected.
That's the current state, right?
And that's there because
as an agent developer,
we have to constantly make this trade-off
between how much autonomy
to give to an agent
and how much safety
controls we want to put.
The more agentic we make an agent,
the more autonomous it becomes.
We feel that and because
of LLM indeterminism,
because of the lack of
safety controls in the agent,
development frameworks,
we don't have the full safety
guarantees that we have.
And this way with AgentCore Runtime,
we are trying to solve few of
them with layered approach.
Let's dive deep into it.
And this where how to contain
what can happen within your agent.
Now, my definition of an
agent is a simple one,
where it's an LLM in a loop.
So you have a task at hand,
you're using an LLM,
and that LLM kind of runs in
a loop to achieve the purpose
and use the tools that it provides.
And that's what an agent
code really is like.
You can use any agent
development framework.
Sometimes you have some controls,
sometimes you have less controls,
but effectively using
an LLM for reasoning,
and then you're acting through tools.
And that's the code that
runs in AgentCore Runtime.
And we provide a strong isolation boundary
across every user session.
Think of it in a way
where every user session
has its own memory,
has its own file system
and CPU resources that are
not shared by anyone else.
Two user sessions cannot cross boundaries,
cannot access each of the data,
and there's no crossfiring
that can happen,
inadvertently or even if
there's an adversarial attacks
that's going on.
And that provides a very
strong guarantee for you.
It's as if there's a clean room
that is created for every user session.
And better yet, once that
user session is done,
everything is removed,
so there's no after the fact
user session can come in
and use any residual data
or context from that.
Now that's a great guarantee
for agent sessions.
Imagine that if there
was a concurrent session
that is running in typical
workloads, like microservices,
there could be possibility if
agent has access to the state,
it can store state on behalf of one user
and may access that same state
on behalf of another user.
That would be very...
That would not be possible
with a strong security
and isolation boundaries
with AgentCore Runtime.
We are using lot of our technology
that we have over the years in AWS
like Firecracker microVM
that we use for a lot,
driving a lot of our
serverless architectures
to within this.
Post that, there is now we are containing
what an agent scaffold
or AgentCore can do,
but agent interact through
their external environment
via tools, right?
That's how they can do.
So even if we are containing
what it can do within that runtime,
there is still a possibility
that through the tools
that we have provided,
it can do a lot more.
It can access state, it
can affect environment,
it can exfiltrate data,
or it can access the data
that you don't want or it's not trusted.
And that's where it's
important to curate the tool
that you're providing to your agents.
It's same as lease
privileges that we try to do
with every other microservices tool.
What actions it cannot
do to not provide it.
An example, a simplistic example
would be that if you're building a chatbot
that should not give
refunds to your customers,
don't provide a refund tool.
So curation tool does help.
And with AgentCore Gateway,
it makes it simpler
because you can provide
your API resources,
your Lambda targets, or
even your MCP targets
and sort of create this abstraction
where you are curating
the tools for an agent.
And it works totally with MCP compliance.
And maybe quick raise of hands,
how many of you already know about MCP,
or Model Context Protocol?
So quite a few, but for
those who do not know,
like there's a very,
it's a protocol that
was launched last year,
November, sort of.
And what it does is that it
provides two functionalities,
or a simplistic where two
functionalities to an agent,
where an agent can discover
tools through list tools,
so it can know what tools
are available to it,
and then it can invoke tool
in a very uniform manner.
And that's what MC protocol dictates.
So any agent can use those MCP server
to discover what tools are available
and then use those to
definitions when it's required
and invoke them.
AgentCore Gateway is
fully compliant MCP server
that you get out of the box.
But what's more important
is even if you have curated that tool
with Lambda Interceptors
that we have launched,
you can do fine-grained access control.
So these are the Interceptors
that work before every tool call,
and even after every tool call.
You can now enforce policies,
which are much more fine-grained.
A certain identity may have access,
a certain it may not have access.
A user that has booked a ticket
should only be processed,
should not only be eligible for refund
versus a user who is not.
You can actually implement
your own business logic
and business rules there.
It's a nice abstraction because
it gives you those controls,
which is outside the
boundary of an agent code.
And again, this helps because
this is more enforceable
and everything goes through it.
The next one, there is
still a problem here, right?
Now that we have contained
what an agent can do,
we've also given curated set of tools,
there is still stuff where,
what if I work and often
agents work on behalf of users,
so they obtain an identity from a user
and they work on behalf of it.
Now, if there are multiple users
that an agent is working on behalf of,
how should it not crossfire?
How does it implement
this on behalf of flows
in a right way where the
identities are propagated,
the authorization controls are implemented
while it's accessing external resources.
And this is where we
developed AgentCore Identity
to do three purposes.
It gives an identity to
your agent, that's one.
It does inbound authentication.
So your end user, you
can bring your own IDP,
you can authenticate.
Much like any other services that we have,
you authenticate who is coming in.
But more importantly, it also
does outbound authentications.
Agents are built to interact
with their environment.
We are giving tools to interact
It can do on behalf of flow.
And AgentCore Identity
manages credentials for you,
token management, and
credential exchange for you.
AgentCore itself doesn't have
access to those credentials.
It only gets token
for the identity that's
working on behalf of,
and then it can use it
to access the tools.
Now that we are also ensuring
that the credentials are right,
we are using the right
tools, and it's contained,
there is also still stuff to
know what an agent is doing.
Now, what we define as a
simplistic definition of an agent,
it's a LLM in a loop calling tools,
it's incredibly hard to debug this.
There are no pretty workflows.
There are no code to go back
to and see what's going on
and why it's happening.
Every request can take a
different path in that whole flow.
LLMs are incredibly resourceful too.
If a path fails, it can
take another undefined path
that you don't know ahead of
time, and that's the feature.
With Observability, you can
see all the session traces
in like across all the components,
including tool calls,
LLM calls, agent code,
and so on and so forth,
and create over the period of time,
what your agent is doing.
You can get a view of that.
You can query CloudWatch logs,
or you can have ready-made
dashboards that you can see.
You can also see over the
period ready-made dashboards
that says how much token usage is there,
which tools are failing
often, which tools are not,
what are you 4XX0s, 5XX0s,
and all of that is available.
With this, there is observability,
but there is still a problem.
If I know what is happening
but I don't know what is
right versus what is wrong.
Making all the tool called successful
doesn't still mean that
the agent was helpful,
it achieved the goal success,
or what I'm trying to do,
or it's relevant to my end user.
This is where the next thing
comes, AgentCore Evaluation,
that we have launched only today.
And this is how it looks like.
So there's a user making an agent call,
and then we already know,
with AgentCore Observability
all of those traces,
whether from AgentCore
or from related AgentCore
services like Gateway, Runtime,
Identity, all of them
get into Observability.
All of them track through one session ID
that you can see all the traces.
And now, what you can do on top of it
is that as an agent owner,
you can define what your criteria are
for saying that what is
right versus what is wrong
for your agent.
You can define your
autoverifiers, autograders,
or we call evaluators for your agent.
There are 13 prebuilt
evaluators that we offer,
but you can write on your own.
So once you write,
and this typical way to
write them is LLM as a judge.
So you define based on the
input is the session trace
and you define to you what
is the right, what is wrong,
and you can evaluate them.
And the good thing is all of this
also comes back to agent Observability.
So again, you can come to
Observability and session,
and you can see based on your evaluation
whether it was helpful, accurate,
and whatever the dimension
that you're interested in.
You can also see a dashboard
where you're seeing
over the period of time,
which sessions are the ones
that are falling short
of your expectation,
these sessions are exceeding.
That's the monitoring process.
The good thing about this,
you can do it online.
So you can continuously evaluate,
you can set up your pipeline with samples,
certain percentage of your
request, and continuous,
and whatever the value it
is you have configured,
it can keep evaluating them.
You can do use predefined evaluators,
there's a dozen of them,
or you can define your own.
And you can easily that
testing phases too,
which doesn't have a
dependency on CloudWatch.
You can just call when
I'm developing an agent
to test my evaluators or test my agents
as I'm developing them.
Now this is great.
Now I can know what my agents are doing,
verify continuously how
they are performing.
But with safety,
I don't want to take chances
of like after the fact.
I know that after the fact
that maybe it didn't do the right thing.
I need more deterministic controls, right?
Before an agent is acting,
or if I know what is going
bad, I want to affect it,
so it doesn't do bad.
And that's where Policy comes in.
And Policy works on top of Gateway.
So let's take a flow that
happens without the Policy.
There's agent, there's
an inbound tool call.
An agent calls the Gateway for
the for the tool invocation,
and the tool invocation
happens from the Gateway.
Now, with AgentCore Gateway
as that interception layer,
you can assign policies,
you can write policies,
deterministic policies,
that apply add the every tool invocation
and that get deterministically enforced.
Now, the nice little,
nice stuff is that you're
not relying on AgentCore
to enforce it.
You're not relying on tools
to have that business logic.
As an agent developer,
you can determine strictly put
it in the AgentCore Gateway.
Similar to evaluators, you
can define it ahead of time.
So there's a policy admin which comes,
define those policies.
Once they're defined and associated
with their AgentCore Gateway,
they get evaluated for every tool call
that you make through that gateway.
And with everything else,
all the policy allow and deny decisions
gets logged in the AgentCore
Observability again
against the same session trace.
So you can see the full
trace what's happening.
We kind of discussed some of this already.
So AgentCore Policy provides
its unified protection for you.
It intercepts and governs all
agent to tool interactions.
There's an operational simplicity to it.
No developer integrations
required for each tool.
Because it's applied at the gateway level,
it's not per tool that you can do.
You can also associate the same policies
to multiple gateways too for agents.
There is auditability.
All the enforcement decisions are logged
and traced into the
AgentCore Observability.
And performance is a key metric here,
because imagine, it's happening
on your transactional path,
in your online path,
and you want to have millisecond
latencies overhead there.
If it takes a lot of time or
it is very resource-intensive,
it cannot be applied for every tool call
without the performance trade-offs.
Let's dive them into a use case
and understand how
overall policy will work.
And we are taking an insurance
agent, as an example,
and a typical agent user sense of prompt.
There's an agent is running,
an AgentCore Runtime.
So that's the container unit.
It has its instructions, it has its tools.
Some of the tools are local
that's implemented within
the agent scaffold.
And then there's an agent
context that's available.
It makes model calls,
which are external to the Runtime,
And it makes tool calls,
which are also external
via Gateway, right?
That's the general four.
There are three tools
that we have provided it.
There's an application tool,
which helps it create an application.
There's an invoke risk model tool,
which helps assess the risk model
for that application that is created.
And then there's an approval tool,
where somebody can approve,
that I approve this insurance application.
Now that's a very simplistic
insurance application.
If I were to put up policies on it,
these are the three steps that looks like.
Step 1, policy authoring.
And in here, I want to enforce a policy
which says in natural language,
let's start with that.
That allow the user to
call the application tool
with the coverage amount
is under $5 million.
So no policy coverage,
no policy application
where coverage amount
is more than $5 million.
And the second one is much
more interesting for me,
the second statement.
If you're not able to
read, I can just repeat it.
If a user has a principle
tag called department,
so if an identity that is calling
has a additional attribute
that department is finance,
then only they should be
able to do risk modeling.
And this is sort of something,
where if there's a different
user that is calling
not from the finance department,
they should not see the risk modeling.
And this is an identity-based
kind of a validation,
not a simplistic validation
on just the tool inputs.
How many of you're aware of Cedar?
Okay, good to find one.
And for this, you don't
have to know Cedar though,
but I'm just showcasing it here
is we are enforcing them through Cedar,
and that's very important,
because Cedar is this policy
authorization language
that has been developed before gen AI.
It's already supported
in API Gateways, Lambdas,
Amazon Verified Permission
is developed and open-sourced by Amazon,
and it's sort of a very formal policy
for policy authorization.
It's much more like Rego.
If anybody's aware of
our Kubernetes and stuff,
very similar to Cedar.
And what is important here
is that even though there's a
natural language definition,
there is a formalization
of it through Cedar.
So you can actually see and
enforce it through that.
That also gives it much more
performant and determinism.
The natural language really helps
in ensuring that if you're
not good at authoring these,
you can just start with natural language.
There's a lot of verifications that we do
that it's actually right.
And in here, it already
shows that it's valid policy,
then you can apply them.
Second one, once we have
created these policies
and associated with a gateway,
now you can just start calling your tools,
or start running your agents.
Same flow, looks like this.
We send a prompt agent
reasons through the model,
decides on a tool.
But before invoking the tool,
now there's an interception
for the policy.
The policy gets enforced,
whether it's an approved
or a denied decision.
In this case, it's an approved.
So it goes ahead and makes the tool call,
the tool result comes in
and goes back as a response
to the end user, right?
It was a deny call, it would've
returned directly from there
and would've moved forward.
The third step is the Observability.
Whether it's allow or deny,
you can come to your Observability traces
and see what is going on,
what policies are approved,
deny the decisions of it.
You can see the payload information.
you can see which resources.
And you can also see, which
is not captured in here,
we will show it in the demo.
You can also see over the period of time
how your policies are working,
how many sessions or
traces they're denying,
how many they're allowing.
And you can see their distribution
over a period of time.
With this, we can actually
see it in action too
through a demo.
Okay, so this is AgentCore console.
Let's start with Gateway.
I've already created a gateway in here.
The gateway name is what is selected.
And you can see inside this gateway.
Gateway associated with an
identity provider, Cognito.
So there's a Cognito identity
that I'm using for inbound.
There are three tools configured.
Going inside one tool,
and these are tools that
we already talked about.
There are two properties it has.
It needs coverage amount
and region as an input.
These are the definition
that goes into the model.
This how model knows how to call it.
Now with these tools
and with this gateway,
there is also a log delivery.
This is where the tracing comes about.
There is vendor logs
that you can configure
where this log should go.
And the tracing is enabled as well.
So all the Observability
will be enabled for this.
Let's quickly run it.
There are no policies yet, right?
It should just run.
It's a very bare bones agent.
Forget about custom claims.
Now we did not add any claims.
There are four tools
here that are created,
but we only added three tool.
And does anybody know where
this fourth tool came from?
Okay, I'm not surprised
because it's very custom for
the gateway that we have added.
And the way to think about this,
that in this case it's not useful,
but there's a search
tool that we have added.
Now, it's not there in MCP spec yet,
the search functionality,
but you can actually do contextual search
based on what your agent is processing
and just get the list of tools from there
versus all the list of tools.
There are just three tools here.
So it doesn't matter.
We can just list all the tools
and provide in the context.
But imagine there are 30 or 300 tools
that you're providing all those tools
and you don't want to provide all of this
in your LLM definition, then
search can come in and help.
Let's move forward with the demo.
Okay.
So in here,
now I'll just try to make
a application request,
providing it's the U.S. region.
We wanted a region and a
dollar amount, $10 million.
And it's a dummy implementation.
It'll approve...
It'll just create an
application for me for now.
Created application.
This works right now without
any policy enforcement so far.
Now, we can go back to the console
and try to see how to enforce,
how to create our policies.
So here we are.
And this is the policy preview.
You can come, you can go
to Create Policy Engine.
Policy Engine, imagine it
is a container of policies.
So you can create many policies,
all of them go into one policy.
We'll name it, in this
case, Underwriting_use_case.
And now we will select a resource.
A resource will be a gateway.
That's where we are
applying these policies.
We'll select the resource.
This is the same natural language
that we talked about and went through.
So again, the same natural
language that we are saying,
don't allow if it's more than $5 million
and don't approve,
and only risk model access
should be enabled for a principle
or a user which has
attribute finance, right?
In real time, you can see
Cedar policies being created.
You can even iterate through that
as you're authoring these policies.
In this case, I'm showcasing.
I got it right in one flow.
You may take a few iterations.
You can see your policies, see the valid.
If they're valid or not.
And even not going through lot into Cedar.
There are three sections
or four sections to it.
There's principle action resource
which identifies who is
accessing, the action is the tool,
the resource is the gateway,
and the when the important part here,
at what conditions are you allowing it?
We validated both.
Both looks fine.
One is on the principle #department_name,
and the other one is
the right dollar amount
that we wanted to do.
So all of this looks fine.
Now we can just create this policies.
There's a validation mode.
I'm just choosing for test purposes.
Permissive, we created these policies.
Now they're still not
associated with Gateway.
So the next step is to
associate with a gateway.
So I'll just associate
with my existing gateways.
We already created a
gateway that we had before.
I'll just go, select it.
And there are two modes for test.
You can just do Emits log only,
where it doesn't enforce,
but it says what a
decision would have been.
It's very useful for you
to see, like, do a dry run
on it before enforcing it.
But in here, I want to show it in a demo
where it actually prevents
from calling that tool,
so it's enforced.
Cool.
We can go back to our agent now,
now that policy's enforced
and run the same agent, right?
Again, there are no custom claims yet.
So it all shows none.
And in here, it's again
very interesting right now.
And if anybody's noticing,
we only see in available
tools one tool right now,
instead of like four
tools that we had before.
And can anybody guess the reason
why there's only one tool now?
Well, what it means is that with Cedar,
it's the deny all is the default.
So by default, unless
you have a permit policy,
it's deny all.
Now, we only configured
permit for two tools.
So the first two, the search
tool, there was no permit,
so that's denied.
The third tool that
was there for approval,
there was no permit, that's denied.
This user doesn't have
the right department.
It does, there's no department set.
So the risk model tool is denied.
The only one that could be,
if the dollar amount is
lesser than $5 million
is the create application.
That's what agent sees.
So this is a very good way,
where your agent never even sees the tools
that it cannot use.
And that's pretty important
because then it cannot hallucinate.
There is no loops where
agent tries something
and then it fails because policy denies
and then it comes back.
Okay, we'll move forward.
And I'm going to try the same thing.
I want to create an insurance
application, U.S. region,
and for coverage, amount of $1 million.
This should be allowed based on our policy
and it should go forward.
Okay, so this work.
Now, we can try,
but it doesn't showcase that
our policies is really working.
So we can try a number which
is greater than $5 million.
Let's say, in this case, $10
million is what we can try.
It's application creation
in the U.S. region,
and amount is $10 million.
I'm just specifying
additional instruction in here
to make the tool call again
because it's in the same context
and agencies that it already
created an application,
it generally sometimes says I
already created an application
so just I'm providing
additional information in here.
And if you see, it
actually failed to call it
because the intercept
happened with a policy
and it failed, we can go back and check.
And now you can see there's
a view traces, right?
That was there before.
We can go there and see if
Observability is helping us.
You can come here.
This is an auto filter
that gets configured here
because you come through that view traces
based on the policy engine.
There is one interaction that
we have had so far, one deny.
And you can see that one trace that's why.
You can come here and find
the information for that.
Yep.
So it says policy is enforced,
and it says the interaction
that is out there.
Now these are the metadata that is there
for the system to see.
And you can actually filter
and configure metrics on all of these.
So these are pretty useful
if you want to have this dimensions
of deny access policy engine,
or metadata around agent or gateway
where you're applying these.
Now we can go back and
try the other policy too,
which to me is a far more interesting one,
which combines the principle attributes
and the context that we are providing.
Okay.
We will go back and try this again.
Cool.
And this time, I will add
custom claims to my identity.
So by custom claims, I'll add those tags
that the department of
the user will be finance
and there'll be other things
like cost center and stuff in that.
And we can see here.
And what this means is that in
your jot token, the Java web,
like the JSON web tokens
that gets to here,
those claims will be present,
those attributes will be present,
and then you can run your
policies against that.
In this case, if you see now, it is there,
department name is finance,
employee level is senior,
and cost center is XYZ.
These are three attributes
that are provided by the IDP
that gets all the way
propagated to the gateway.
And now you can implement
policies on this.
Now, in this case, and this is
something that is important.
Previously, we did see that
there was only one tool
that was listed.
Now you can see there
are two tools listed,
because the other two
had any permit policy.
They'll never come, unless
we add any permit policy.
But for the other two,
the both conditions are satisfied right.
So there's a department in finance,
so that's why the invoke risk model tool
is available to the
agent and it can use it.
We can go forward and try
the same approach now,
where now we'll try to
just trigger the risk model
and see how if it makes that call or not.
And if you cannot see,
yeah, I'm typing in,
I first typed in, I want
to do the risk model,
but I didn't provide all the information.
And it say like it needs more information.
And that's what I'm providing in here.
Once I provided it, did the risk modeling,
and it provided me the status as success.
So the call did go through.
The counter example to that
would be I can add a department
and set the department other
than finance, say engineering,
which people do not maybe trust us enough
for engineers to make
this finance decision.
And you will see that the list
tools itself will not show.
And in here, you can
see the list tool itself
is now showing,
just the create application
and not the risk model.
And if you make the invoke call,
the same interception will
happen and it'll not go through.
I'm going to move forward from this.
So that's the full policy
in action that you can see,
both the policy got applied.
And the nice thing about
it is that it gets applied
to both the tools available to the agent
and at the invoke time,
and across all the tools that
are available via the Gateway.
Now coming back to the
agent safety framework
and the layered architecture that we have.
Runtime helps to contain what can happen.
Identity helps to control
who is allowed to act
and what actions they can take.
Gateway controls what tools
you're providing to agent,
what an agent can do.
And with Observability,
you know what happened.
We are enhancing both
Gateway and Observability now
with policy
to now have fine-grained
access control over this.
And imagine this Lambda
Interceptor that we talked about
is another way to implement,
find good access control,
much more do it yourself,
and policy is much more managed for you.
Then Observability helps you...
Beyond observability
evaluation helps you verify
if your agents are working or are doing,
are working right for you.
With all these features,
where we want to get to
is that this trade-off
between agent performance and agent safety
should not be pushed to
the application developer.
There should be foundational controls
that are provided through
agent platform infrastructure
that helps you build safe agents
without trading off autonomy
for AI agent applications.
If you need more resources,
here is the launch blog for the policy,
and there are more GitHub code samples
that are ready to try for you.
Thank you.
I'm open for any questions.